billiger einkaufen oder hilfe für den
einzelhandel was uns die senkung der
mehrwertsteuer im konjunkturpaket
wirklich bringt ein zaun ums weiße haus
der präsident verbarrikadiert sich vor
demonstranten die weiter gegen rassismus
und polizeigewalt protestieren und 13
jahre fahndung im fall medien zu dem
mutmaßlichen täter aus deutschland gibt
es jetzt immer mehr details
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers und nahm den allen die
welt an diesem freitag willkommen bei
uns ab heute nach langer corona pause
auch wieder mit dem sport
ich freue mich christen genau und wir
freuen uns auch alle sehr später mehr
guten abend wir beginnen mit den
auswirkungen der berliner milliarden
entscheidungen auf unser aller leben und
die deutsche wirtschaft ein punkt im
konjunkturpaket der bundesregierung der
uns alle dazu bringen soll mehr zu
konsumieren ist die absenkung der
mehrwertsteuer
sie soll von juli bis dezember sinken
von 19 auf 16 prozent zum beispiel für
mode oder elektrogeräte der ermäßigte
satz der beispielsweise für viele
lebensmittel gilt von 7 auf 5 den staat
kostet das rund 20 milliarden euro geld
das er nicht einnimmt
dafür soll der bürger so die wirtschaft
ankurbeln
ob das funktionieren kann und wenn ja
wie zeigt isabel de la vega frank barth
allmess muss in seinem obstladen bald
neue preisschilder aushängen die
mehrwertsteuer bei lebensmitteln soll
von sieben auf fünf prozent sinken
an seine kunden will er das weitergeben
ja natürlich der kunde muss ja auch was
davon haben wir haben ja alle genug
gelitten und werden noch eine zeit lang
leiden müssen und da werde ich das auch
weiter geben
es ist nicht viel aber die menge macht's
dann rewe lidl aldi die großen
lebensmittelketten signalisieren sie
wollen die steuersenkung an ihre kunden
weitergeben
trotz des aufwands und der kosten für
die umetikettierung der ware
die maßnahme soll schwung in den handel
bringen und plötzlich ist in der politik
ein streit entbrannt ob die nur bis zum
jahresende geplante steuersenkung nicht
dauerhaft gelten könnte ökonomen wie
michael hüther warnen es ist wichtig bei
nachfrageimpulse sie zu befristen denn
es muss jetzt zeitgenau zielgenau
passieren also auf den konsum orientiert
und in dieser phase im zweiten halbjahr
und deswegen auch angesichts der kosten
die sich damit verbinden sind 20
milliarden wird es nicht eine
verstetigung geben können
ob die senkung ein konjunkturelles
strohfeuer entfacht ist unsicher der
handel wird nachdem lockdown ohnehin mit
rabatten möglich dass die wirkung
verpufft bei einem großeinkauf wird's
wahrscheinlich ein paar prozent
ausmachen aber ob ich deswegen weil es
den fernseher kaufen würde glaube ich
nicht für mich jetzt die mehrwertsteuer
auf jeden fall nicht ein grund mehr zu
kaufen und nicht überall wird die
steuersenkung an den verbraucher
weitergegeben
der wiesbadener gastronom ohr es die das
schafft das nicht erst brachen mit dem
lockdown die gewinne ein
dann stiegen die lebensmittelpreise alle
produkte die wir einkaufen sind deutlich
zwischen 10 und 15 prozent teurer
geworden
dementsprechend können wir die preise
nicht senken aber wir werden sie halten
so händler oder dienstleister wie ihn
ist es vor allem wichtig dass die kunden
überhaupt kommen
ig metall chef jörg hofmann hat die
spd-spitze dafür kritisiert dass sie
eine kaufprämie für schadstoffarme
benzin und diesel fahrzeuge im
konjunkturpaket verhindert hat hofmann
warnte in der augsburger allgemeinen vor
einem massiven vertrauensverlust der
beschäftigten gegenüber der
sozialdemokratie man dürfe die für
deutschland so wichtige auto branche
nicht in einer geisterfahrt gegen die
wand fahren sagte er
wie die menschen in der korona krise
entlastet werden können darum ging es
heute auch im bundesrat
hier kommen ein paar wichtige neuerungen
die jetzt auch die länderkammer passiert
haben eltern die wegen corona nicht
arbeiten können weil sie die kinder
betreuen bekommen länger lohnersatz vom
staat bis zu 20 wochen lang statt die
bisher nur sechs rentner bekommen ab
ersten juli mehr geld im osten steigen
die bezüge um 4,2 im westen um 3,45
prozent
und wer eine immobilie kauft muss
künftig nur noch einen teil der
maklerkosten zahlen maximal die hälfte
den anderen teil zahlt der verkäufer die
usa erleben tage bei denen nicht klar
ist ob am ende ein aufbruch steht und
das problem von polizeigewalt endlich
richtig angegangen wird oder ob das land
ins chaos abgleitet es gibt weiter
massive proteste überall in den usa und
die hauptstadt washington wirkt
zunehmend wie ein heerlager das weiße
haus weiträumig abgeriegelt in des trams
ist in washington tage war er nicht
gesehen worden nun dritter auf präsident
frank bejubelt den leichten rückgang der
arbeitslosenzahlen nach der korona
pandemie wenig sagt er zu den protesten
im land nur dass die gouverneure hart
durchgreifen sollen doppel seid nicht
stolz ihr müsst den job erledigen ruft
mich anruft die national gerade wir
haben so viele leute ihr müsst die
straßen beherrschen ihr könnt das nicht
geschehen lassen
es nennt sich die straßen beherrschen
und feiere die wirtschaftliche erholung
und ein neues paket mit darlehen für
arbeitgeber
das würde auch george floyd der ein
weißer polizeigewalt verstarb
anerkennung george jetzt gerade herunter
und sagt dass das eine großartige sache
ist die unserem land geschieht das ist
ein großartiger tag für ihn ist und für
alle ein großer tag hinsichtlich
gleichberechtigung
zuvor hatte trump einen brief auf
twitter gerät bietet in dem die
demonstranten von washington mit
terroristen gleichgesetzt werden die
versucht er tag für tag immer weiter von
sich entfernt zu halten
der zaun um das weiße haus wird in immer
größeren kreisen gezogen das gefällt
washingtons bürgermeisterin nicht sie
gibt einer straße am weißen haus den
namen schwarze leben zählen black live
mutter immer wieder auch unschöne
momente bei den protesten polizisten in
buffalo schubsen und überrennen einen 75
jahre alten demonstranten und helfen
nicht
amerika steht am scheideweg chaos oder
politische lösung
amerika steht am scheideweg und wir
gehen einen live nach washington zu
elmar theveßen elmar wovon hängt es denn
jetzt ab in welche richtung sich diese
proteste entwickeln wie viel dauerhaften
erfolg sie letztlich haben werden ich
glaube es hängt im wesentlichen von zwei
faktoren ab das eine ist dass menschen
aller bevölkerungsschichten ethnien auch
altersgruppen auf die straße gehen in
den nächsten tagen vielleicht werden wir
das am wochenende schon erleben die
zustimmung für den präsidenten sinkt
derzeit auch insgesamt aber auch ganz
besonders in den kern wählerschaften die
hat zb bei weißen ohne
hochschulabschluss oder auch bei weißem
katholiken in den usa also wenn sich das
auf den straßen reflektiert dann könnte
es hier eine wechselstimmung geben und
das zweite ist eben dass namhafte
persönlichkeiten sich an diesen
protesten beteiligen
der ehemalige verteidigungsminister der
republikaner william cohen hat heute
morgen im fernsehen gesagt er sieht das
weiße haus führt das land auf den weg in
eine diktatur das sind sehr starke worte
der ehemalige stabschef und dort schwamm
john kelly hat ähnliches heute morgen
gesagt aber es bedarf auch andere
persönlichkeit wenn die mitmachen und
und das ist entscheidend wenn es
friedlich bleibt dann hätten diese
proteste das potenzial hier im land
vieles zu verändern sicherlich auch die
politische gemengelage danke emma nach
washington
nach dem gewaltsamen tod von george
floyd versammeln sich seit tagen
weltweit menschen um ein zeichen gegen
rassismus und polizeigewalt zu setzen
wie hier bei einer demonstration in
frankfurt das motto black life center
die bedeutung eines menschenlebens ist
unabhängig von der hautfarbe das geht
gerade als slogan um die welt kniefall
in londons innenstadt auch hier sollen
menschen dem verstorbenen floyd und der
protestbewegung in den usa ihren respekt
und dann gucken wir jetzt in der sendung
auf den aktuellen stand der korona
pandemie in deutschland da ist der trend
weiter positiv die zahl der
neuinfektionen geht weiter zurück
nimmt man den durchschnitt der letzten
sieben tage stecken sich derzeit 330
menschen pro tag mit dem virus an
insgesamt zählt die johns hopkins
universität fast ein hohn
85.000 fälle davon gelten mehr als 100
68.000 als genesen 8645 menschen sind in
verbindung mit 19 gestorben
immer wieder zeigt sich aber wie schnell
eine einzige ansteckung zu einem
größeren ausbruch führen kann wie der
leicht sind weniger konsequenzen für
viele hat beispiel göttingen hat mehrere
familien das ende des muslimischen
fastenmonats ramadan gefeiert die folge
mindestens 120 corona fälle
hunderte in quarantäne schulen und
mehrere kitas geschlossen und heute ein
crooner massentest in der hochhaus
tiefgarage alle bewohner müssen hin
kristina wiegel cdu und elisabeth
schmidt berichten das hochhaus in
dettingen sozialer brennpunkt und corona
hotspot die behörden besorgt die zahl
der erkrankten steigt und damit die
alarmstufe wir müssen jetzt auf orange
umschalten orange ist die stufe vor rot
und orange bedeutet wir haben eine
zuspitzung wir nehmen die situation sehr
sehr ernst seit heute gibt es
massentests in der tiefgarage des
gebäudes nicht freiwillig sondern
verpflichtend bis sonntag will die stadt
bei allen 700 bewohnern einen abstrich
nehmen notfalls mit unterstützung der
polizei
denn in der vergangenheit hatten sich
einige wenig kooperativ gezeigt heute
lief die aktion weitgehend problemlos es
gilt einen überblick zu bekommen denn
die infektionen haben kreise gezogen
auch in einem altenheim bereits ein
bestätigter corona fall wenn es dann
einmal da ist geht es auch in den zahlen
wieder sehr sehr schnell
und deswegen finde ich ermahnt uns
erstens jeder diese ausbrüche weiterhin
aufeinander zu achten
auch in bremerhaven fast 100 corona
fälle die in verbindung stehen einer
evangelischen pfingstgemeinde seit heute
ist in der stadt der kritische
schwellenwert
50 neue infektionen pro 100.000
einwohner überschritten
die vollzeit ist enorm und wenn es uns
gelingt dass wir diese infektion auf das
cluster begrenzen wird es auch weiter
gut handelbar sein
dafür tun wir alles diese grundschule
auf die mehrere kinder aus der gemeinde
gehen hat die stadt vorsorglich
geschlossen
bis auch hier alle testergebnisse
vorliegen urlauber könnten schon in
wenigen tagen in europa mit deutlich
weniger grenzkontrollen rechnen
bundesinnenminister horst seehofer sagte
nach beratungen mit seinen eu-kollegen
ein großteil der staaten werde seine
beschränkungen an den binnengrenzen am
15 juni beenden auch deutschland die
eu-kommission hofft dass ende juni dann
im ganzen schengen-raum wieder freie
fahrt möglich ist welche reise regeln
aktuell für welches land gelten das
finden sie bei uns online unter zeigen
wir ihnen auch wie und wohin die
deutschen in diesem jahr verreisen in
krisenzeiten machen jetzt viele urlaub
wie anno dazumal die interaktive story
zum durchscrollen in der zdf- heute- app
es gibt in deutschland den wunsch und
die notwendigkeit ganz neu zu denken
wenn es um die frage geht wie kommen wir
von a nach b
in einer großstadt zum beispiel aber
auch auf dem land da bewegt sich also
einiges auf der anderen seite steht
immer noch das alte
personenbeförderungsgesetz schon alles
jetzt ist die reform des taxi und
fahrdienst marktes in deutschland einen
schritt weitergekommen aber wirklich
klarheit gibt es nicht für die kunden
dafür ein eckpunktepapier der
regierungskoalition das liegt jetzt fest
dass neuer anbieter leichter in den
markt einsteigen können das klassische
taxigewerbe befürchtet aber durch die
konkurrenz etwa von uber enorm unter
druck zu geraten christian hübscher
viele nutzen sie längst private
fahrdienste oder pulling services die
man per app bucht die bundesregierung
will solchen anbietern nun den
rechtssicheren markteintritt erleichtern
in einem vertraulichen entwurf der dem
zdf vorliegt heißt es die beförderung
von personen mit personenkraftwagen ist
nicht genehmigungspflichtig
niemand außer den taxifahrern bräuchte
dann noch einen
personenbeförderungsschein zum ausgleich
müssten taxifahrer künftig keine
ortskunde prüfung mehr machen
stattdessen ein navigationsgerät an bord
haben und nur noch einen kleinen
fachkunde ausweis vorlegen
das taxigewerbe fürchtet dennoch um sein
geschäft wir sehen schon die gefahr dass
hier eine öffnung für über und co
stattfinden soll
das ist erstmal schlecht fürs taxi
gewerbe das ist perspektivisch aber auch
schlecht für die neuen anbieter im
bereich pulling das ist schlecht für den
fsv und dass es am ende auch schlecht
für die verbraucher denn ein preiskampf
könnte drohen doch auch die privaten
anbieter kritisieren den entwurf aber
seit jahren in deutschland gerichtlich
ausgebremst soll demnach auch weiterhin
zur rückkehr nach jeder fahrt
verpflichtet bleiben seine fahrer dürfen
nicht wie taxis auf gäste warten
leider zeigt das vorliegende papier
wieder einmal wie schwer sich
deutschland aber mit der digitalisierung
tut der vorschlag würde bedeuten dass
mietwagenfahrer auch weiterhin jeden tag
viele tausend kilometer in unseren
städten zurücklegen müssen von anfang an
war der protest der taxifahrer laut
verkehrsminister will den neuen entwurf
deshalb heute nicht wirklich
kommentieren
eine findungskommission aus bund und
ländern muss das unmögliche schaffen
das personenbeförderungsgesetz so ändern
dass alle glücklich sind die korona
krise sorgte an der börse für auf- und
absteiger die lufthansa muss den
deutschen aktienindex nach fast 32
jahren verlassen
der kurs der aktie war seit jahresbeginn
massiv eingebrochen
der gesamtwert des dachs
gründungsmitglieds etwa 4,9 milliarden
euro ist zu wenig für die erste
börsenliga im dax sind die 30
wichtigsten aktien unternehmen in
deutschland
an die stelle der lufthansa rückt jetzt
ein e mobil
lilien konzern die deutsche wohnen unser
nächstes thema jahrelang keine spur von
der kleinen madeleine mccann jetzt gibt
es große hoffnung doch noch die wahrheit
über das schicksal der des in portugal
verschwundenen britischen mädchens
herauszufinden
die ermittler halten einen vorbestraften
sexualstraftäter aus deutschland für
mord verdächtig christian b wegen
anderer delikte sitzt er im gefängnis in
kiel
sein name taucht offenbar schon seit
langem in den akten auf auch in
zusammenhang mit dem fall betten
da stellen sich einige fragen moldau
berichtet führt eine neue spur im fall
madeleine mccann auch zu verschwundenen
inga die staatsanwaltschaft stendal
sucht nach möglichen verbindungen wie
sich derzeit noch nicht öffentlich
äußern
inga aus schönebeck in sachsen-anhalt
war fünf jahre alt als sie am 2 mai 2015
aus einem wald bei stendal während eines
familienausflugs verschwand umfangreiche
suchaktion und ermittlungen konnten
nicht klären was mit ihr geschah
christian b der tatverdächtige im fall
madeleine mccann soll 90 kilometer
entfernt ein grundstück mit verfallenen
gebäuden besessen haben bei der
durchsuchung des geländes soll die
kriminalpolizei einen stick mit
kinderpornographischen material
sichergestellt haben
der 43 jährige sitzt derzeit in kiel
eine alte haftstrafe ab er hat ein
beachtliches vorstrafenregister
im grunde ist er seit 17 jahren eine art
berufskriminelle hat mit sexuellen
missbrauch und einer harten strafe zwei
jahre begonnen als er 17 war und zuletzt
sieben jahre wegen einer brutalen
vergewaltigung einer älteren frau in
portugal 2005 die ermittler sind davon
überzeugt dass christian b als täter der
kleinen madeleine in frage kommt doch es
fehlen noch zentrale beweise wie die
leiche ziel der fahnder ist es deshalb
möglichst viele informationen zu
gewinnen über christian b der bundesweit
europaweit unterwegs war
teilen sie uns ihr wissen wird jedes
auch nur kleinste detail ist für unsere
mittel ermittlung von immenser bedeutung
nur durch neue zeugenaussagen lassen
sich die vorwürfe gegen christian b
beweisen
da sind noch viele fragen offen jetzt
machen wir einen schnitt in der sendung
ich habe es vermisst schön dass ich
jetzt wieder sagen kann
kristin was gibt es neues vom sport so
charmant tut mir gut ja es gibt einiges
neues tag für tag mehr das doodle ist
das ziel zum ersten mal unter trainer
hansi flick
zum dreißigsten mal meister zum
zwanzigsten mal dfb pokalgewinner und
genau dafür fühlt sich der fc bayern
münchen bereit auch wenn noch
hochkarätige aufgaben warten zunächst
morgen in leverkusen
sie haben sich zuletzt in herausragender
form präsentiert die bayern und das soll
so weiter gehen wir sind gierige auf
tore wir wollen wir wollen spiele
gewinnen der gegnerische trainer ist
schwer beeindruckt ganz ehrlich wenn ich
bayern sehe dann genieße ich von das
fußball als fußball liebhaber aber auch
die bayern blicken auf einen
leverkusener kh werz zum einen weil sie
ihn gerne in den eigenen reihen hätten
also ich glaube es gibt wenige trainer
die etwas dagegen hätten wenn keine
arbeits in ihrem in ihrer mannschaft
spielen würde
da will ich mich auch mit einschließen
zum anderen weil er in der rückrunde
schon neun tore erzielt hat er könnte
vielleicht auch den bayern gefährlich
werden
nationalstürmer timo werner steht
offenbar vor dem wechsel von rb leipzig
zum fc chelsea mit einer ablösesumme von
60 millionen euro wäre der 24-jährige
der teuerste deutsche transfer in der
premier league der vertrag soll kommende
woche unterzeichnet werden und neben
fußball gibt es von morgen an auch
wieder basketball ohne zuschauer und
unter strengen hygiene regeln zehn klubs
spielen in münchen bis ende juni den
deutschen meister aus der fc bayern ist
nicht nur in den letzten beiden jahren
deutscher meister geworden sondern jetzt
auch noch gastgeber für die restlichen
35 liga spiele bringt aber im kampf um
die meisterschaft keinen vorteil finden
jedenfalls die bayern
es ist jetzt mehr oder weniger für alle
die gleich voraussetzung ist auch dass
wir die körper körbel vielleicht
bisschen in den ersten tag besser kann
als die anderen die dann irgendwie nach
ein zwei wochen auch das glaube ich wie
gewohnt finden nun zwei wochen
eingewöhnung wären allerdings recht lang
denn das ganze final turnier dauert nur
gut drei wochen erst zwei fünfergruppen
dann ko spieler viertelfinale und am 28
juni soll der neue deutsche meister
feststehen wenn nichts dazwischenkommt
stichwort disziplin das sauber motto
danke christian willkommen zurück
und zum schluss ist zeit für eine
inventur und zwar in der wildnis schnee
leoparden zu zählen ist für forscher
nicht so einfach erstens sind sie
meister in der tarnung und dann werden
sie wegen des klimawandels auch immer
seltener
man kann sich die überraschung also
vorstellen bei den forschern angesichts
dieser bilder in kirgisistan 15 schnee
leoparden haben die kameras erwischt und
die leoparden hatten dann selbst einiges
zu forschen
ja das war möglicherweise die letzten
bilder die da gefilmt wurden vor dieser
kamera der tag morgen ist wettermäßig
zum abhaken aber für sonntag hat gunther
tiersch bessere aussichten
ich empfehle ihnen das heute schon mal
mit der kollegin marietta slomka um 22
uhr am wochenende freut sich hier petra
gerster auf sie wir sehen uns montag
wieder und von uns allen im team 19 in
einen angenehmen freitagabend tschüss
[Musik]
guten abend liebe zuschauer auch morgen
erwartet uns wieder windiges
schauerwetter kreisverkehr der
tiefdruckgebiete in mitteleuropa und
darüber hören uns immer wieder diese
regengebiete nach osten hin
morgen wird es nicht mehr ganz so
kräftigen regen geben zumindest nicht in
der mitte deutschland sind schauer
abends beruhigt sich das wetter für den
sonntag sieht es dann in der mitte
deutschlands ganz freundlich aus aber
jetzt erst mal in dieser kommenden 18
erstmal schauer und gewitter über die
elbe nach osten ab im süden regnet es
noch längere zeit und von westen lockert
mehr und mehr auf morgen haben wir dann
erst mal am vormittag im norden
nordosten freundliches wetter da kommt
die sonne raus genauso wie südlich der
donau sonst regen vom schwarzwald bis
zum erzgebirge
auch neue schauer zum teil auch an der
nordsee und diese schauer breiten sich
nach osten aus bis zur elbe etwa zum
teil auch richtung berlin aber da kommt
nicht mehr viel runter sie lösen sich
dann meist auf ab und zu sagen gewitter
mit dabei wie zum beispiel auch an den
alpen und vom westen lockert auf bei
diesem recht starken südwest wird die
temperaturen dann meist so zwischen 15
und 19 im südöstlichen bayern 21 grad
ja und die der sonntag bringt uns dann
tatsächlich in der mitte deutschlands
mal etwas sonnenschein montag und
dienstag mäßig war wechselhaft aber im
osten und norden ist es sonnig ich
wünschen einen schönen abend und machen
sie's gut